what I want to do in this video is build
up some tools in our toolkit for dealing
with sums and differences of random
variables so let's say that we have two
random variables x and y and they are
completely independent they are
independent independent random variables
random variables and I'm just going to
go over a little bit of notation here if
we wanted to know the expected or if we
talked about the expected value of this
random variable X that is the same thing
as the mean value of the mean value of
this random variable X if we talk about
the expected value of y the expected
value of y that is the same thing as the
mean the mean of Y if we talk about the
variance if we talk about the variance
of the random variable X that is the
same thing as the expected value of the
squared distances between our random
variable X and its mean so and that
right there squared so the expected
value of these squared differences and
that is can also be can also you could
also use the notation Sigma squared for
the random variable X this is just a
review of things we already know but I
just want to reintroduce it because I'll
use this to build up some of our tools
so you do the same thing write this with
random variable Y the variance the
variance of random variable Y is the
expected value of the squared difference
between our random variable Y and the
mean of Y the mean the mean of Y are the
expected value of Y squared and that's
the same thing as Sigma squared of Y
there is a variance of Y now you may or
may not already know these properties of
expected values and variances but I will
reintroduce them to you and I won't go
into some rigorous proof actually I
think they're fairly easy to digest so
one is
is that if I have some third random
variable let's say I have some third
random variable that is defined as being
the random variable X plus the random
variable Y let me stay with my colors
just so everything becomes clear the
random variable X plus the random
variable Y what is the expected value of
Z going to be the expected value of Z is
going to be equal to the expected value
of x plus y and this is a property of
expected values I'm not going to prove
it rigorously right here but it's the
expected value of x plus the expected
value of y or another way to think about
this is that the mean of Z is going to
be the mean of X plus the mean of Y or
another way to view it is if I wanted to
take let's say I have some other random
variable let's let me I'm running out of
letters here let's say I have the random
variable a and I define random variable
a to be X minus y so what's its expected
value going to be the expected value of
a is going to be equal to the expected
value of X minus y which is equal to you
can even either viewed as the expected
value of x plus the expected value of
negative Y or the expected value of x
minus the expected value of y which is
the same thing as the mean of x minus
the mean of Y so this is what the mean
of our random variable a would be equal
to and all of this is review and I'm
going to use this when we start talking
about distributions that are sums and
differences of other distributions now
let's think about what the variance of
random variable Z is and what the
variance of random variable a is so the
variance the variance of Z the variance
of Z and just to you know to kind of
always focus back on the intuition it
makes sense if X is completely
independent of Y and if I have some
random variable that is the sum of the
two
then the expected value of that set of
that of that variable of that new
variable is going to be this the sum of
the expected values of the other two
because they are unrelated if I think if
if my expected value here is five and my
expected value here is seven completely
reasonable that my expected value here
is twelve assuming that they are
completely independent now if we have a
situation if we have a so what is the
variance what is the variance of my
random variable Z and once it again I'm
not going to do a rigorous proof here
this is really just a property of
variances but I'm going to use this to
establish what the variance of our
random variable a is so if if this on if
this squared distance on average is some
variance and this this one is completely
independent and its squared distance on
average is some distance then the
variance of their sum is actually going
to be the sum of their variances so this
is going to be equal to the variance the
variance of random variable X plus the
variance of random variable Y the
variance of random variable Y or another
way of thinking about it another way of
thinking about is that the variance the
variance of Z which is the same thing as
the variance of X plus y of X plus y X
plus y is equal to is equal to the
variance of X plus plus the variance of
random variable Y and hopefully that
makes some sense I'm not proving it to
rigorously and you'll see this in a lot
of statistics books now what I want to
show you is that the variance of random
variable a is actually this exact same
thing and that's the interesting thing
because you might say hey why wouldn't
it be the difference we had the
differences over here so let's
experiment with this a little bit the
variance the variance so I'll just write
write this the variance of random
variable a is the same thing as the
variance of I'll write it like this is x
minus y which is equal to which is equal
to you could view it this way
which is equal to the variance which is
equal to the variance of X plus negative
Y right these these are equivalent
statements so you could view this as
being equal to just using this over here
the sum of these two variances so it's
going to be equal to the sum of the
variance of X plus the variance plus the
variance of negative Y and what I need
to show you is that the variance of
negative Y of the negative of that
random variable is going to be the same
thing as the variance of Y so what is
the variance of negative Y the variance
of negative Y is the same thing as the
variance of negative Y which is equal to
which is equal to the expected value the
expected value of the distance between
negative Y the difference the difference
between negative Y negative Y and the
expected value of negative Y squared
that's all the variance actually is
that's all the variance actually is now
what is what is the expected value of
negative Y right over here or actually
even better let me factor out a negative
1 so what's in the parentheses right
here this is the exact same thing as
negative 1 squared times y plus the
expected value of negative Y so that's
the same exact same thing in the
parentheses squared so everything in
magenta is everything in magenta here
and it is the expected value of that
thing it's the expected value of that
thing now what is the expected value of
negative Y the expected value of
negative Y I'll do it over here the
expected value of the negative of a
random variable is just the negative of
the expected value of that random
variable so if you look at this we can
rewrite this I'll write give myself a
little bit more space we can rewrite
this as the expected value of the
variance of negative Y is the expected
value this is just 1 negative 1 squared
is just 1 and over here you have Y and
instead of right
the expected value of negative Y that's
the same thing as minus the expected
value of y so you have that and then all
of that squared now notice this is the
exact same thing this is the exact same
thing by definition as the variance of Y
so we just showed you just now so this
is the variance of Y so we just showed
you that the variance the variance the
variance of the difference of two
independent random variables is equal to
the sum of is equal to the sum of the
variances you could definitely believe
this it's equal to the sum of the first
this variance of the first one plus the
variance of the negative of the second
one and we just show that that variance
is the same thing as the variance of the
positive version of that variable which
makes sense your distance your distance
from the mean is going to be it doesn't
matter whether you're taking the
positive or the negative of the variable
you just care about absolute distance so
it makes complete sense that that
quantity and that quantity is going to
be the same thing now the whole reason
why I went through this exercise kind of
the important takeaways the important
takeaways here is that the mean of
difference is the mean of differences
right over here so I could rewrite it as
the mean of the differences of the
random variable is the same thing as the
differences of their means and then the
other important takeaway and I'm going
to build on this in the next few videos
is that the variance of the difference
the so if I take a random if I define a
new random variable as the difference of
two other random variables the variance
of that random variable is actually the
sum of the variances of the two random
variables so these are the two important
takeaways that we'll use to build on in
future videos anyway hopefully that
wasn't too confusing and if it was you
can kind of just accept these at face
value and just assume that these are
tools that you can use